Schon wieder eine spektakuläre Überraschung,
die der Stern “Beta Pictoris” da für
uns bereithält.
Eine neue Studie hat nämlich jetzt enthüllt,
dass dieser massereiche blutjunge Stern nicht
nur von einem, sondern sogar von mindestens
zwei gigantischen Planeten umkreist wird.
Wie können wir uns “Beta Pictoris C”
vorstellen und wie gelang diese überraschende
Entdeckung?!
Clixoom Science & Fiction - hier gibt es täglich
spannende Science-Videos, abonniert den Kanal
und aktiviert die Glocke nur dann verpasst
ihr nichts.
Los geht’s!
herzlich willkommen!
Das muss man sich mal vorstellen: Der massereiche
Stern Beta Pictoris ist so jung, dass sich
seine Entstehung mit dem menschlichen Stammbaum
abgleichen lässt.
Der Stern, der etwa 63 Lichtjahre von uns
entfernt ist und sich im Sternbild des Malers
(Pictor) befindet, wurde vor etwa 20 bis 23
Millionen Jahren geboren.
Im Vergleich mit der Sonne, die in etwa 4,6
Milliarden Jahren alt ist, ist das wirklich
extrem jung.
Als Beta Pictoris also geboren wurde, trennten
sich auf der Erde gerade die sogenannten Menschenartigen
- also die Gibbons, Menschenaffen und unsere
direkten Vorfahren - vom Rest der Primaten
ab!
Diese erdgeschichtliche Epoche wird in der
Fachsprache auch als Miozän bezeichnet.
Und weil Beta Pictoris eben so blutjung ist,
hat der massereiche Stern schon für manche
Überraschungen gesorgt.
Die Astronomin Anne-Marie Lagrange bezeichnet
es als das wahrscheinlich “ beste Planetensystem,
das wir kennen, um die frühen Stadien der
Bildung und Entwicklung solcher Systeme zu
erforschen”.
In den 80-er Jahren gelang Astronomie-Teams
eine echte Premiere: Sie konnten eine Aufnahme
anfertigen, die erstmalig den Nachweis der
sogenannten protoplanetaren Scheibe ermöglichte.
Ein großer Meilenstein für die Astronomie!
Solch ringförmigen Scheiben aus Gas und Staub
befinden sich um sehr junge Sterne herum - aus
ihr können sich mit der Zeit Planeten entwickeln.
Auch unsere Erde und ihre Nachbarn sind mal
aus solch einer rotierenden Scheibe aus Gas
und Staub um die junge Sonne entstanden. 2009
sorgte Beta Pictoris für die zweite Sensation,
denn damals wurde in diesem Sternensystem
ein erster Planet entdeckt: Beta Pictoris
B - ein wirklich großer Brocken!
Jetzt hat ein französisches Astronomie-Team
für eine weitere Überraschung gesorgt.
Denn den Fachleuten ist es gelungen, einen
weiteren Planeten um Beta Pictoris aufzuspüren.
Sein Name: Beta Pictoris C.
Laut der Studie handelt es sich auch bei ihm
um einen gewaltigen Brocken.
So weist er etwa die 3.000-fache Erdmasse
auf.
What?
Zum Vergleich: Jupiter, der fünfte und größte
Planet unseres Sonnensystems, bringt es gerade
einmal auf 318 Erdmassen!
Und noch mehr konnten die Fachleute bereits
über den neu entdeckten Planeten herausfinden:
Er ist wohl 2,7 Mal so weit von seinem Stern
Beta Pictoris entfernt wie die Erde von der
Sonne.
Um seinen Stern zu umrunden, braucht er 1.200
Tage.
Bedingt durch die hohe Rotation um seine eigene
Achse, dauert ein Tag auf dem neu entdeckten
Planeten nur knapp acht Stunden.
Die spektakuläre Entdeckung wurde durch die
sogenannte Radialgeschwindigkeitsmethode möglich.
Diese Methode eignet sich sehr gut, um Planeten
zu entdecken.
Auch die Hinweise bezüglich eines zweiten
Planeten um Proxima Centauri konnten damit
erst vor kurzem aufgespürt werden - wir hatten
darüber bei Clixoom Science & Fiction berichtet.
Dafür wird die Radialgeschwindigkeit der
Sterne in Bezug zur Erde gemessen, um die
hypothetische Planeten kreisen könnten.
In bestimmten zeitlichen Abständen werden
dafür hochaufgelöste Spektren des Sterns
aufgenommen.
Denn durch die Zusammensetzung eines Sterns
und seinen lichterzeugenden Prozessen entstehen
ganz charakteristische Spektren.
Daraus können Fachleute dann sogenannte Dopplerverschiebungen
erkennen, die wiederum Rückschlüsse auf
die mögliche Existenz eines Planeten zulassen.
Denn die Radialgeschwindigkeit in bezug zur
Erde kann immer sehr genau bestimmt werden.
Kreist ein Planet um einen Stern taumelt der
Stern in bezug zur Erde.
Durch dieses Taumeln können dann Planeten
aufgespürt werden.
Weiterhin sind in die Analyse auch Messungen
des HARPS-Spektrografen des La-Silla-Observatoriums
eingeflossen.
Und das Forschungsteam ist optimistisch, dass
noch weitere spannende Entdeckungen folgen
werden.
Denn auch die ESA-Raumsonde “Gaia” und
das “Extremely Large Telescope” in Chile
sollen das junge System um Beta Pictoris demnächst
genauer ins Visier nehmen.
Erster Exo-Vulkanmond entdeckt!
What.
Das wird immer spektakulärer!
Anklicken, anschauen und Astro Comics TV abonnieren.
Einer meiner absoluten Lieblingsknäle!
Bis dann, bleibt dran!